hello kiddies and parents how you doing
hope you're well we're all well here
college is in good shape except you're
not here that's all too bad so I've got
two purposes today and one is to say
that we're resuming classes online only
on Monday as was scheduled your classes
will be at the normal times unless you
hear something different from your
teacher and the second is I want to say
them about the spirit in which we're
going to go back to work along the way
I'll make a couple of other points the
first one is you're wondering when are
we going to invite you back and I will
tell you that we get a lot of phone
calls from students almost all say come
back now and we get a lot of phone fair
number phone calls from mothers mostly
saying no don't bring them back so I
want to reassure the mothers that 2002
levels one is we are going to come back
at the earliest possible moment and the
second thing is when we come back all
students will have the option to stay
home if they want to now your mother's
will be thinking yeah but if you invite
them back I'll have trouble keeping them
here and I respond that's your problem
and anyway you might be tired of them by
then
so there's that now the second purpose
is about the spirit of it and I have a
few things to say about that because
this is an important topic this is a
test of character and intellect of the
kind that shapes human souls and
portrays them in their excellence why
character well it'll be easy won't it to
sink into some kind of lassitude while
you're away not everybody's here you
don't see people in person there plenty
of distractions and yet it's true
nobody ever learned any serious thing
except by intensity you got to work hard
everybody does every minute to know any
great or important thing any serious
thing it always requires that think of
the lesson that's evident in all of this
that's going on right now everything is
in motion the stock markets never fallen
as far as fast as it's fallen I don't
know that we've ever attempted to
suspend the work in great countries for
months at a time in time of peace but
never in war actually for that matter
it's just we're trying radical new
things and it looks like there aren't
any rules but there's something to
notice in the middle of all that and
that is a motion calls your attention it
makes you look for a theme or a rule in
the middle of it these events in society
how are we to understand them it raises
the whole question what is the purpose
of life is it just to live is it to live
well what is living well take what
requirements are there in this radical
situation that is exactly what Hillsdale
College was founded to think about that
is its activity that's what it does and
now I gets to do it in a new way under
some adversity so the test of character
is it's not heightened because college
itself every difficult thing is the test
of character and a formation of
character - but it's a it's a new kind
of test because you know it's a shameful
thing to waste a day of your life
especially if you're young and talented
because what you do today will affect
all the days to come and you have many
to come I'll say a word about the
faculty if you want to know their spirit
do a google search for what Eric
Hutchinson wrote today he just sent it
to me a few minutes ago about when he
was here and 9/11 struck he was a
student here before he became the great
man you know you should read that right
that's the temper of our faculty they're
all learning how to do online teaching
we don't even like it but you know I
mean we'd rather be with you right but
we're gonna be good at it starting soon
the technology is kind of cool
don't mistake that it's a replacement
for the real deal but it's pretty good
and you can learn a lot and it will be
exciting to learn to learn this way so
we're gonna undertake that we're gonna
undertake that in a good spirit we are
going to use this time
to the maximum effect and then the
minute I can justify a decision to come
back I will invite you all back with
great joy and pleasure in the meantime
get ready for Monday get your boots on
please let's have a great term